[Music]
what's up everybody how you doing this
is Pete also known as Naldo giving you
another one of our impressions first
looks at this game called children of
morta this developer is a dead mage and
the publisher is 11 bit studios now I
would like to take a couple of seconds
here to tell you a little bit about what
I have seen in this game and how I
played it I played it for a little over
an hour and a half and that does not
include the time that I ended up playing
it at PAX East 2018 so I wanted to tell
you that this game I really really love
I am a fan of that pixel art feel that
ended up being in children of Moreh
now I didn't know the background or
anything like that when I played it in
2018 when I was at PAX East but this
time I ended up taking a look at it more
in depth I took my time playing it and
the the gameplay oh I just I can't tell
you how much enjoyment I was getting out
of it
so just all right so let's give you a
little bit of a background of what
children are Mora is about children of
morta is about how you are a father at
the start of the of the game and you are
looking to defeat all of the the
darkness that is in the mountain that I
guess we call it mount morta because
that is the mountain that they live on
now sort by the grandmother telling you
that there is a problem in the mountain
and in doing so they decide ok we have
to investigate so they end up sending
the father into this mountain to take a
look at it now while you're in this
mountain you are kind of learning the
ins and outs of the game your heel your
your blocking or striking your dodge and
it's very simple controls and the what
you end up doing is you end up going
through this area and you eventually
find your daughter and she ends up
following you around and you end up
having like little combat sequences and
scenes with them and throughout this
whole time you're getting background
story information story about Mount mora
the creatures how the people around you
are and the game feels full of life now
I really really enjoyed how this felt
now what I will tell you is that there's
a very similar feeling game so that so
moonlighter is made from 8-bit Studios
also and this game is very similar to
that in those fields its 8-bit and
you're essentially running around
killing swiping killing monsters and
getting their drops and eventually after
you complete the first oh I bought I
what I played I almost completed the
first stage on the first scale I got
that first boss down to about about half
health a little less than half health
and that I failed and died and then
you're brought back to life in the main
town and then you're home on the side of
Mount morta and you learn that you know
you can end up upgrading your weapons
and your skills and things like that for
the whole family
now they allude to the fact that you are
upgrading skills and doing things for
the whole family now
I know from patsies that you have
different characters you could pick from
now when you first go into that first
level you only get the option of the
father or the eldest daughter
this daughter is a person with a
crossbow now the father figure is sword
and shield so you have different types
of gameplays and game styles now patsies
I know that there's a magic user guy
that allows you to shoot lightning bolts
and do other things like that so that
you have different characters that
you're going to be able to play as and
as you feel fit for your game your play
style now being that I've played a lot
of different types of sword and board
type characters I figured that's gonna
be the character I play as so that's
what I end up playing and I really
learned to grab a hold of that character
very strongly now there's also a
leveling system to allow you to have
your character grow now when your
character grows and stronger you can
have him either being more to have a
your shield produce a thorns ability
which when you get attacked from
creatures they take damage or if you end
up having a regular wanna make your
sword stronger you can end up doing that
after you gained enough experience
you're gonna end up putting it into
levels into your levels and you can end
up making your character stronger now
from what I saw you can make your
character stronger and stronger and
stronger and when you go up a certain
amount of levels like I went up 4 levels
in that first level system I ended up
being able to pick from another two sets
of skills one of them always told us
being a passive which allows you to gain
more maximum health I think it was for
your whole family now over time it seems
that your whole family is going to be
able to give the each character of the
family that is going into mount morta is
going to allow your team as a whole to
become stronger in knowing that and
seeing that it makes you want to go back
and play it again and again
so that your other characters are
strengthening the one that you end up
playing the most now I get when I was in
PAX East I played it not it felt very
bland and I was kind of like me this is
all right but now that I'm sitting here
playing it I actually I'm really really
enjoying it and this is really really
fun now it also has the feature of
two-player you'll see that option when
you go inside the player select screen
to have one player or two player which
is great now if I recall it allows you
to do a split screen type sequence and
this is actually really good for me
because I'm gonna call it my brother and
be like yo I know you love these types
of games you're gonna come and play
you're gonna come over and play and help
me Pam it helped me beat this because I
actually wanna play and I want to beat
it now the other interesting thing about
this game is the art style being the
pixelated art style now pixelation has
been around for a couple years now
and people have to realize that with
pixelation you're not going to have that
defined type look but still they are
able to make these environments
beautiful and the graphics in this game
are amazing I love them they they did a
great job the controls and the gameplay
and the I guess you'd call a game play
if you will it's very smooth now most
people are probably used to almost like
a clicker based game like Diablo which
is not like this at all
now this game is a lot easier to play on
a controller than it is your keyboard
mouse now that's how I ended up playing
I played it on a old-school Xbox 360
controller because that's what I have
and that's what I like to feel for and
it played beautifully and I loved it so
what I would say is that children Remora
is definitely something that I would
pick up and I would definitely say you
should go out and grab it now this copy
we
from a it's I love it it's great and I
would love for everyone to you know pick
it up and show you know your support for
this game
now I'll let's say thank you very much
for listening to this first impression
hopefully I'll end up beating this soon
and I'll end up giving you guys a full
review when I'm finally done now thank
you very much and I would like you all
to say hit that subscribe button above
thank you for hanging out and watching
this video and make sure you guys are
checking out the Arnold's podcast and I
will see you guys later have a great day
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you